banderas serbias en melbourne y en
belgrado en donde la situación del
tenista serbio novak djokovic se está
convirtiendo en un asunto de estado un
relato que su familia se encarga de
alimentar para los padres del atleta a
su hijo es víctima de un asunto político
honesto se mantienen a nuestro novak
nuestro orgullo en cautiverio no va que
serbia y serbia es novak
están pisoteando a novak y con esto
están pisoteando a serbia y al hacerlo
pisotean al pueblo serbio a xavi y
gasteiz serviu y shorts hillary me
siento fatal desde ayer las últimas 24
horas lo han tenido como prisionero no
es justo no es humano las autoridades
australianas rechazaron el miércoles la
exención médica del jugador para entrar
en el país desde entonces permanece en
un hotel de melbourne para solicitantes
de asilo sin acceso a sus enseres
personales según su familia djokovic
deberá esperar hasta el lunes cuando un
tribunal australiano decida si debe ser
deportado o no desde el gobierno de
camberra tienen clara su postura
las reglas son reglas y no hay casos
especiales las reglas son las reglas es
lo que les dije ayer esa es la política
del gobierno y
la noticia tampoco ha dejado
indiferentes al resto de jugadores del
torneo el español rafael nadal dejó este
jueves muy clara su posición everybody
it's a free to take
el toma sus propias decisiones y todo el
mundo es libre de tomar sus propias
decisiones pero luego hay algunas
consecuencias por supuesto que no me
gusta la situación que está pasando en
cierto modo lo siento por él pero al
mismo tiempo conocía las condiciones
desde hace muchos meses
ai field sorry for him a la espera de
que el caso se resuelva el propio
ministerio de exteriores serbio presentó
una queja ante el embajador australiana
en el país el trato hacia djokovic dicen
ha sido indecente